as the row about allegations of sleaze
continue the government is focusing
its attention elsewhere last night the
new domestic violence bill was passed by
parliament
promising new protection for victims
well let's speak now to the safeguarding
minister victoria atkins who joins me
uh this morning um are you confident
that the bill having passed will
completely protect uh those in
situations of domestic violence we know
that the numbers
have risen through uh lockdown and those
people now coming out
of lockdown will they be 100 protected
well this this bill is a truly landmark
bill we know that there are 2.3 million
adult victims of domestic abuse in this
country
and of course children who live within
abusive households as well
and this bill first of all puts a
definition of domestic abuse in many
forms it can take
but which is important for commissioning
of services at local level but it does
so much more than that
we are making real meaningful changes to
the ways in which family courts operate
because we know that abusers sadly can
often try to use the family courts to
continue the abuse
we're prohibiting non-fatal
strangulation we're prohibiting
uh the use of threats to use revenge
porn we're
making changes to the so-called rough
sex defense clarifying the law on that
so there's a huge amount of work that
we're doing
to help victims of domestic abuse and
also inc
critically to stop perpetrators we're
seeing record levels of investment under
this government
in programmes to stop perpetrators
because we've got to stop this cycle of
abuse this
perpetrator is going from one
relationship to another
and i think this is a real body of work
that the bill provides the foundations
for but we're very conscious
that the hard work starts now
implementing it the bill however has
received criticism
over how it deals with with stalking
after the amendment
requiring offenders to be monitored on a
national
register was dropped why would that be
dropped i mean surely
a register actually keeping tabs on
offenders
is going to help those that are being
abused well in fairness i think this
bill has received
uh support from across the political
spectrum
i know you're focusing on that
particular point but genuinely this has
been a
real um it's been parliament at its best
i would say because
we've listened to ideas and suggestions
and where
we've been able to where we think they
will work we've absolutely listened and
then
acted on this particular measure we we
looked very very carefully at it
it's very technical it's about how we
manage serial offenders uh and also
the most violent and sexual offenders
outside of the domestic abuse context as
well as
within a domestic abuse context but we
have spoken we've worked really closely
with baroness royal who was the
peer bringing this amendment forward we
have um
very much understood some of the
concerns that have been raised we're
going to improve guidance we're i'm
setting out a new framework
we're finding ways to address the
concerns that have been raised in the
house
but we just we weren't convinced that
this particular amendment was the way to
fix that but of course we will continue
to keep this under review
a national register is not a a good idea
i mean many lay people will think that
it makes perfect sense
yeah so the problem with registers um is
that
uh if someone what we don't want is
people
falling between the gaps so we have a
really really um
thorough system of managing a serial
offenders both violence and sexual
offenders as i say both in and out of a
domestic
context 85 000 offenders are managed
under this system
called mapper and um the
what we want to do they will be stalkers
but they will also be sadly sexual
offenders they'll
they will be um very very violent
offenders and
uh what we're doing is is looking at the
system as a whole we are very conscious
that
uh the some parts of the system have
outlived their usefulness the visa
system is more than 20 years old
so next year we will be piloting a brand
new digital
uh forum which we believe will really
answer some of these concerns that have
been raised but the critical point about
managing stalkers
is about the decisions that are taken at
local level to manage the risk of these
people
and that's what we need to focus on
rather than we think setting up a new
register
let's move on to uh the prime minister
regarding um
allegations of corruption and saying
that there's nothing
to see um when the electoral
commissioner said
it has reasonable grounds to launch an
investigation
surely shouldn't the prime minister just
actually say
who paid for the refurbishments in the
first instance rather than allowing all
these investigations to be launched
well the prime minister has set out uh
his case very clearly actually in the
house of commons on wednesday he was the
most direct
question though has he in the comments
he didn't answer that direct question
well he's answered the questions that
were put to him and and
um i know that he was asked yes or no
did he pay for the refurbishments and he
didn't answer yes or no
well as i say the prime minister has
answered those questions as you know i'm
on here to talk about the domestic abuse
bill
but the prime minister has answered the
questions he has
very much given his answers to the house
and i i do wonder you know here i am
today
we've got this amazing piece of
legislation that will help
as i say millions of people across the
country and it would be nice if just
today we can focus on that well
we have we have that's how we started
the interview we have asked you about
that
but also people people are wanting to
have answers to questions that the prime
minister isn't simply answering
well i don't accept that as i say he's
answered questions in the house of
commons
we had the we've had the announcement of
uh lord guyt being appointed as the
independent adviser
uh and of course you know these reviews
these inquiries will
uh take their path but the prime
minister has answered to the house i i
don't really feel i can add to that
but but ultimately as downing street has
said the prime minister will be the
the ultimate arbiter of of any inquiry
uh that's like marking your own homework
isn't it
well no the way that we work our
democratic system in this country is
that the prime minister
the prime minister of the day wins the
general election uh and
he or she appoints the government and
then he or she is answerable at
the dispatch box in parliament and of
course in due course at the ballot box
to the electorate
and so he must have control over who is
in his government he's answerable for
their actions it seems to me
the consequences of some of the
suggestions that have been flung around
in the press this week
haven't really been thought through i'm
not sure anyone wants
an unelected uh unaccountable advisor
impeccable and with all of the integrity
that
uh lord guy has i'm not sure that that
is an addition to our constitution that
uh
we want to walk into without fully
understanding the consequences
we do know that sir alex allen quit the
role after the pm
essentially overrode his findings
regarding pretty patel
and bullying how do we know that the
prime minister is going to listen to any
findings of
any investigation there's some nine
investigations at the moment
well first and foremost this process has
been transparent
uh and i think you know in terms of the
previous investigation that has been
settled the
home secretary apologized uh on national
television
um for the uh findings of that review
and so again i'm just i'm not sure i can
add anything more to what we've ignored
it
the prime minister ignored it well
namely that
um the you know the the prime minister
has to have
uh the control of the government has to
have the
confidence that his ministers are the
ministers he wants to
uh exercise the incredible
responsibilities that
ministers have in government and that
seems to me that that has always been
the case and must continue to be the
case
minister thank you very much for
speaking to us this morning thank you